[Applause]
freedom day in england july 19
the day the country lifted almost all
coronavirus restrictions
other parts of the uk soon followed
but did it come too early
freedom day meant no more masks and no
more social distancing
about half the adult population was
fully vaccinated officials were
confident the threat to public health
had been minimized
but now britain has among the highest
confirmed cases in europe
more than 40 000 a day
welcome i'm ben fazoulen medical experts
are calling on the british government to
bring back social distancing the
government is refusing relying instead
on booster shots to protect the most
vulnerable
this is how the uk wants to get through
the winter a third covet 19 shot for 30
million vulnerable people
but many vaccination centers have closed
and the vaccination program is sluggish
76 year old iva garfinkel died while
waiting for his booster shot his son
blames the slow pace
he was literally
going out shopping going into his
hospital checkups and things like that
and he caught covered
and um 11 days later um he died i
genuinely do think a booster might have
saved his life
case numbers are the highest in europe
but a vaccination rate above 67
has kept down severe infections and
deaths
after lifting all restrictions in
england the government strategy seemed
to be working but the tide is turning
the uk registered 223 deaths on tuesday
nearly a thousand people were
hospitalized
we have relatively low
social distancing measures
compared to much of europe the other big
thing is
um i think
immunizations that immunity from either
previous infections or immunizations are
almost certainly beginning to wane
the projection offered by the
astrazeneca vaccine the most widely used
in the uk appears to decline
significantly over time
but boosters are urgently needed for
other vaccines too
the uk's national health service says
it's time to act they're calling for the
government to trigger its plan b a set
of measures including mandatory mask
wearing vaccination passes in certain
settings and recommending people work
from home
the government is rejecting calls to
trigger fresh restrictions
at a news conference on wednesday the
health minister said he expects up to a
hundred thousand cases a day in the
coming weeks which means more severe
infections and deaths are likely
inevitable
he appealed to the public for voluntary
support
if we want to secure these freedoms for
the long term
then the best thing that we can do is
come forward once again when that moment
comes there are many more things that we
can all do
to help contain the spread of this virus
like
you know meeting outdoors where it's
possible and if you can only meet
indoors letting in fresh air like
wearing a face covering in crowded
enclosed spaces
when asked why ministers in a packed
parliament weren't wearing masks the
health minister conceded good point and
said lawmakers should set an example
winter is coming and healthcare workers
are already feeling the pressure
yet another concerning new variant is
making its rounds in the coming weeks
may well be decisive for the united
kingdom
let's bring in heidi larson director of
the vaccine confidence project at the
london school of hygiene and tropical
medicine she joins us from brussels
did freedom day come too early for
england in your opinion
yes i think it was a bit um freedom day
was perhaps a bit premature but
i think that you know we have to think
about freedom in relative terms because
um
i
i think too much too soon is is
um
let's put it this way the
pandemic is highly volatile i don't
think anywhere in the world
is ready for full freedoms if you think
of
it kind of frames restrictions as being
not freedom but we're actually trying to
get freedom from the disease
so yes uh in trying to throw off all the
restrictions in one go
it was probably too early i think it
needs to be a
an evolving process
i mean it sounds like a great public
relations campaign but when you look at
the reality of things uh the vaccination
rate for example isn't it far too low
for such freedoms
yes and it's not just about i mean
vaccinations definitely have lulled in
terms of uptake there was a real peak
during the summer and all the willing
were coming forward now we're in a more
difficult stage but i think it's it's a
harsh reminder
that it's not just about the vaccines i
mean people have also shed masks
distancing um are more lacks about that
the gatherings um are you know there are
gatherings of a lot of people uh all the
things that
viruses love
um for for propagating are are now
you know there for them uh there for the
virus so i think that um
we we need to
take this in cautious steps and and
there will be some freedoms in some ways
but um i i think we can't do it all in
one go without having some situation
like now where it's the viruses is
coming back
so how do you get the rest of the
population vaccinated
well i think
it's hard to ask
although what i was going to say people
are going to need patients but it's a
hard ask 18 plus months almost two years
into the pandemic
people are feeling pretty impatient but
also it's taken an economic toll on some
people it certainly affected schooling
so i under the understand the government
wanting to
please the people as it were with the
sense that we're getting closer to
normal
um
or whatever
normal was
um
but but i do think uh
this story is not over at all we can see
other places in the world that
had it under control a bit more like in
asia and now are facing resurgence um
eastern europe is is really having quite
a a challenging time
uh so this is uh
we really still need to be quite
cautious i think some freedoms some
mobility but you can have more mobility
if people comply with with masks at the
end of the day it's all about human
behavior
and
well heidi what about portugal and the
scandinavian countries will they
encounter the same problems with their
freedom days
well i think for portugal and
scandinavia and any other country
considering opening uh freedoms that
they're going to need to be
careful with how they do it i think the
lesson from the uk is not to do
everything
stop restrictions across the board
while people are still unvaccinated and
while the virus is still raging so i
think if they
do it with steps it will be fine
um
let's see how they what decisions they
make at the time
and besides the decisions governments
make what about us what what about the
way
or the the right way for us to live with
the virus what would that be
well you it's a really important point
because not all governments are making
the best best decisions so at the end of
the day we do have our own judgment and
personally i would say given the fact
that this virus is still
hyper infective and
uh and circulating and there are quite a
few still unvaccinated people even
though we've done quite well overall in
europe uh and the uk
uh lately it's it's slowed we should
still wear i would wear masks i would
particularly encourage it and and i
think it should be required in public
transport
i would avoid crowded places um and and
just
protect yourself and and protect others
we still need to be cautious if we want
real freedom uh in the truest sense with
the virus behind us
heidi larsen london school of hygiene
and tropical medicine thank you very
much
here's a good question now for derek and
for viewers who may have just recovered
from covet 19.
how soon after having coveted 19 can a
person get it again
so you had covid maybe you got really
sick and now you hope that your
naturally acquired immunity
will protect you in the future and it
will at least to some extent but
but not perfectly and likely not forever
um
going on two years into the pandemic now
the cdc in the u.s
still says that
re-infections are rare
as time goes on though a lot of experts
believe that'll probably change
as the average person's
immunity wanes
exposure has also grown much more
widespread in many communities and the
delta variant is a lot more
transmissible
than ancestral variants so
two more factors that increase your
chances
of getting it again um one recent study
published in the lancet that was based
on pretty complex models it was a little
scary
it postulated that if sars kobe 2
becomes endemic
in people who have already had covet 19
once they could on average get it again
less than one and a half years later the
good news is that if you've had the
disease and recovered you can lower your
risk of re-infection
by getting vaccinated anyway
that doing that is a good idea is backed
up for example by evidence from the
state of kentucky
in the u.s a study there
found that people who'd been infected
and didn't get vaccinated afterwards
that they were more than twice as likely
to be re-infected as someone who did get
vaccinated afterwards in that situation
early data indicates that messenger rna
vaccines in particular
provoke an even more
powerful immune response
in recipients who've already had the
disease
it's a phenomenon that the media is
calling a superimmunity
and that turbocharged immune response
seems to occur
even after just a single shot of the
vaccine
[Music]